oggi a grandissima richiesta tornano da
james challenge ma un essenziale dovuto
particolare senza led con berlino il
cagnolino berlino che fanno ciao ci sono
anch'io correlate l'anno scorso abbiamo
fatto da flash a led che in cui merlino
se gli e valentini cisl ha in mano
ancora un cucciolo piccolissimo questa
volta rifaremo la challenge lui ha già
un anno e qualche mese però la faremo
con ingredienti slime giganti alla fine
dovrà uscire un gigante che ci sono due
ciotole perché sarà totti invece
l'essere contro italia 1 dovrete votare
se vinco io se vince evitare in base a
90 slime trieste ma anche la simpatia di
vita alla prossima ma sceglierà tutto
berlino noi metteremo per terra gli
ingredienti che ancora non ci sono qua e
poi metteremo anche le crocchette lui
sceglierà prima il mio ingrediente è poi
gli ingredienti di vitale quanti più
dirti che abbiamo qui non vedo l'ora di
vedere come destinato il tus live
lasciate un mi piace se volete altre
sale slime 30 mila mi piace faremo
un'altra sala in slang stata voi
scrivete nei commenti che charlize line
volete che facciamo come è una cosa
importantissima
anzi due cose importanti cosa segui dove
su instagram se ancora non mi seguite il
nome a vita stories è la seconda cosa è
che a fine di questo video aprirò questo
pacco misterioso che è un ricevuto da
youtube un sacco nero molto misterioso
quindi guardate figlio fino alla fine
perché lo offriremo assieme ma ora
andiamo subito a chiamare berlino
dapprima mettiamo gli ingredienti
vi è poi chiamiamo berlino e vediamo
cosa sceglie iniziamo con con la bianca
o con la trasparente ok con la bianca e
con la trasparente sistemata assieme ai
pezzettini di crocchetta io spero che
berlino permesso il vela con la
trasparente ma vediamo vediamo
[Applauso]
ma quando la pioggia è quindi anche per
me che la trasparenza questa cosa
cercando altri progetti gioco bambini
dominicani ok per mac alla trasparente
verrà un super slime speriamo solo che
non mi capiti in verde tra i controlli
notti segni bene ciliberti che faceva
uno slide motivi per molti curiosi
giochi
passiamo ora ai colori secondo turno
sono solo colori fluo primo che
sceglierà sarà il mio è il secondo sarà
chiarita eccoli qua tutti i colori fluo
quindi abbiamo l'arancione il rosa il
verde e il giallo fluo
abbiamo già messo dal croccantino qui
vero colore che adesso siamo pronti per
far entrare il merlino merlino arancione
che è stata fortunata
quindi tu rosa arancio la potete fare
cambio di cibo sarà entrata e che è
molto carino questa ragione su persi
lungo mi è stato più bello perché serva
amorosa
invece un aspetto curioso berlino grazie
verde oppure rischiamo tutto dopo così
vediamo di che colore diventa tutto
mischiato assieme d'accordo adesso tocca
a rosa rosa suo fantastico muri messo
tanti è toccata ok mentre invece il
terzo turno sarò a colori metallizzati
guarda un po cosa abbiamo di berlino
berlino non solo giorno questo quanto e
come i colori metallizzati pronti ora
facciamo entrare berlino vediamo quale
serie per me il primo per me secondo per
vitale by merlino di un po a me lasciamo
questo oro il gioco ma è in mezzo
marrone come bronzo
però possiamo fare cambio bronzo con
rosa non lo so forse ha ragione brutto
molto impressionista nel senso che il
prossimo sia marrone basta perché sono
diventa troppo marrone brutto passiamo
al prossimo turno marino perché mi sento
bene per me ti ha convinto vita la mia
[Musica]
non è vero merlino che cosa dire per il
quarto turno abbiamo gli champs e nello
specifico abbiamo uno shampoo celeste
uno rosa pur avere paura e poi ce
l'abbiamo un altro più che dovrebbe
essere semplicemente bianco quindi quale
sceglierà un berlino berlino 6 bros
per me
è piaciuto cinese poderosa almeno un
colore carino rosa opera tante bolle lo
slice e per me invece celeste bravo
berlino sia stato bravo meno male che
non ho scelto questo usciamo come tutti
si era salvata anche se la maledizione
del verde cioè non penso al vento ma
raramente lo shop
speriamo almeno che diventi bello
scoppiettante questo slang gigante
nostra cotone remi un uomo sempre che ho
fatto una pozione e sei stato fortunato
anche il succo e sia molto celere che
bei colori era per ora sono un po
particolari questi slide novelle
entrambi ma il mio è bello linea entrato
bravissimo ma che nascondono no no no ma
la passiamo all'ultimo turno e per
l'ultimo tour non abbiamo fa ed ecco la
decorazione frisch polpa linea rosa
palline rosse e queste di nomi rigore
come si chiamano zarzis l'acb quindi le
disposti kudo un pochino diverso vediamo
cosa servirà merino il primo sarà per me
è il secondo per unità le vie per me e
può ospitare in palline rosse che
fortuna sono super potete io odio con il
lato all'altro come berlino è stato
bravissimo evitiamo un altro premier
facciamo indovinare guardate nasconde
premetto vediamo se berlino indovina
seduto per di notte di non guardare si
sono divertite che bello e tanti feriti
google sta aspettando un altro premietto
questo è l'ultimo berlino per mettere
questi gli stressi disse sono un po
complicati perché se attivo troppo lo
slime cadono viene sto qualcosa io
perché facciamo cadere sempre quindi
dovevo stare un po attenta il brutto
gesto swipe
speriamo che esca bene e ora andiamo
finalmente a mescolare vediamo di che
cover di menta no non perderli no perché
per me sia forse stati 28 arancione sono
sempre vestito è stato brutto ma è
diventato un colore tra di essi anche
una consistenza orribile che brutto
vedevo che non portati così a un pochino
meglio magari fa dei suoni bellissimi e
io parlo siamo prono sta accadendo
dentro lo stagno la mia palestra
trattenuto tra l'arma lei ristagna un mi
piace
mettiamo marrone marrone marrone ci
credo sei sempre così fortunato il
momento per primi se tu altro
ingrediente 0 le palline erode parli le
rosse perché capita al colore del tour
live non troppo perché se non lo so come
una fine cosa che abbiamo già un
vincitore
vediamo ora andiamo ad attivarli ok ora
andiamo ad attivarli tutti poi potrete
vederli e votare chi vince pronti 32
[Musica]
l'esito un colore
marino kiwi noti fu granita lo meno a
verde di andata male
e ancora un po appiccicoso perché non
volevo attivarlo troppo perché parte le
palline anche se ne sta già perdendo
vantaggio comunque può vedere la
consistenza è un pochino un pochino zhik
lì perché ho messo un sacco di shampoo
però fa un sacco di suoni ora sentiamo i
suoni tante bolle quindi può anche non
essere bellissimo ball menu fa dei super
suoni smr vediamo ora pelle di vitale
dibatte fra golosone
no
no il colore bellissima e cm fra
golosone profumo ha tantissima fa un
sacco di rumore tipos correggete ma che
c'entrano le bolle e dirti se per
carlino anche queste palline rosse ci
stanno bene che assomigliare un po e se
metti che ci sono sulle fragole ecco
perché l'ho voluto chiamare quelli sono
neri è un bene questi due rossi allora
vediamo se adesso fa ancora le scoregge
the ones va ovviamente come tutti gli
slam che fa vitale è stato attivato poco
poco troppo
sì un pochino troppo infatti ora che è
più tanto tanto elastico però dai
comunque non è male in confronto allo
slime granita al kiwi di anita del molto
più bello lo slime fra golosone time fra
golosone di vita mia
granita di doni tolkien milanese votate
nel sondaggio ma che fai
andiamo ad aprire il pacco misterioso si
era bizzarri te lo slime voleva
vantaggio tutto e andiamo aprire il
nostro pacco misterioso da youtube
penso di aver capito che cos'è
sicuramente avrete capito anche voi ma
non sono sicura vediamo
[Musica]
sa benissimo che bella brava vibrazioni
offriamo è pesantissimo anche non si
possa credere che è reale questo è il
golf lei button che viene inviato da
youtube come premi una volta che si
superano un milione di iscritti e non ci
posso credere
ok vediamo se c'è scritto percorso che
c'è la famosa lettera di susan la il
capo supremo di youtube che scrive sei
più grande di vancouver più di venezia e
sei anche più grande di las vegas un
milione di iscritti
magari ha immaginato che magari hai
immaginato questo giorno per un lungo
tempo scusate ma sotto la doccia
istantaneamente quindi non sono super
rapida o magari non hai mai pensato che
avresti raggiunto questo obiettivo che
sareste cresciuta così tanto
in ogni caso niente poi uguagliare la
soddisfazione di scoprire che la tua
creatività dei tue idee e la tua voce
parla a un milione di persone attorno al
mondo sappiamo che essere in grado di
toccare le vite di così tante persone è
già un conseguente un premio
siamo incredibilmente orgogliosi di
tutto quello che hai fatto quindi
speriamo che accetterà i questo ha
creato la world oro continuerai a
crescere e non vediamo l'ora di vedere
quando raggiungerà i il prossimo
sentivo 10 milioni iscritti sembra molto
lontano ma ricordati di giorni quando
e riferisce di aver raggiunto umili un
migliaio di iscritti continua a usare
continua a sognare in grande e continua
a creare seghe ispirazione per tutto
quello che facciamo comunque volevo
ringraziarvi perché questo a word e
vostro numero qua questo qui ci siete
tutti voi
tutto questo non sarebbe mai stato
possibile se non fosse per voi che avete
iniziato a guardarmi magari dai primi
giorni da anni fa ho anche da poco a chi
è arrivato da poco nella story sterili e
tutto grazie a voi e sono felicissima vi
ringrazio tantissimo continueremo a
vivere un sacco di avventure assieme e
iniziato tutto
lassù c'è la world dei 100.000 e vi
ricordo che quando ho ricevuto quel
awards
pensavo non raggiungerò mai un milione
di iscritti è proprio impossibile non ci
riuscirò mai ma vi ricordo di credere
sempre in voi stessi e non dimenticatevi
mai di seguire i vostri sogni anche se
magari ora ci pensate e pensate noi miei
sogni sono troppo grandi non ci arriverò
mai invece sì
ogni cosa è realizzabile se continuate a
crederci sv impegnate mi raccomando non
mollate mai
io vi ringrazio tantissimo ancora e ora
vi lascio qua 4 caselline su cui
cliccare per vedere i nostri altri video
cliccate su quella che preferite e
cristiani
no
[Musica]